The Marvel Cinematic Universe's streak of
near-universally adored releases may one day
end, but not this year.
Early preview audiences have taken to Twitter
in droves to rave over Spider-Man: Far From
Home, with many pegging it as the very best
cinematic outing for the wall-crawler so far.
And considering the fact that Sony Pictures
Animation's Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse
recently took home a Best Animated Feature
Oscar, that's really saying something.
While there's still a moratorium on critical
reviews, this didn't stop fans who got a sneak
preview of the film from absolutely losing
their minds in the vaguest possible terms.
For instance, two-time Emmy Award-winning
sports reporter Heather Catlin tweeted
"Far From Home is by far my favorite Spider-Man
movie. Warning, you’ll have to watch at
least twice."
We know what you're thinking: what about Sam
Raimi's Spider-Man 2, which some consider
to be among the finest superhero films ever
made? You know, that train scene is still
awesome.
Twitter user KevinMcCarthyTV has your answer.
"Far From Home has dethroned Sam Raimi’s
Spider-Man 2 & is now [my] favorite Spider-Man
film. What’s insane is that I can’t even
tell [you] why I’m so in love with this
film because it would be a spoiler. Gyllenhaal
is incredible. Holland re-confirms as the
best Spidey to date. Amazing."
McCarthy was so excited he even had to send
a second tweet expanding on his thoughts from
the first tweet, heaping praise on director
Jon Watts.
"I don’t think I’ve been this excited
to re-watch a film since Jordan Peele’s
Get Out & Us. Watts masterfully layers incredible
action, storytelling and character development
into a film that will be a whole new experience
on the 2nd watch. 2 of the best end credits
scenes ever."
Geek Bomb founder Maude Garrett loved the
film's tone compared to the seriousness of
Avengers: Endgame, and was particularly enchanted
with Jake Gyllenhaal's Mysterio - not to mention
the post credits scenes.
"Spider-Man: Far From Home is SUCH a good
movie! Jake Gyllenhaal suits up & completely
embraces his role in its entirety & he’s
clearly having a blast. This is such a refreshing
film after the heaviness of EndGame. The post-credit
scenes are a MUST WATCH & will blow your dang
mind!"
CNET reporter Sean Keane agreed with Garrett's
assessment of Gyllenhaal's performance, and
also reserved some praise for Zendaya as well.
"Major kudos in particular to Jake Gyllenhaal
for his super engaging performance as complex
character Mysterio, and Zendaya, who brings
depth in her massively expanded role as MJ."
"MJ, I…"
"...am Spider-Man?"
"No, of course I'm not…"
"I mean, it's kind of obvious."
Brandon Davis of ComicBook.com, meanwhile,
was just blown away by everything.
"Spider-Man: Far From Home is an absolute
home run. It’s SO much fun. It’s huge
in itself and for the future of the MCU in
the most surprising ways. Tom Holland, Jake
Gyllenhaal, just a lethal, awesome combo!!
I cannot wait to see this movie again. And
again."
The Playlist editor-in-chief Rodrigo Perez
felt this one was even better than Spider-Man:
Homecoming, but warned that spoilers could
be a major problem.
"Spider-Man: Far from Home far superior to
its predecessor & really delightful, [with
a] terrific theme of trust well-threaded throughout.
Could say more, but it's spoiler-laden, full
of fun secrets, so be careful who you follow
and what they say.
And finally, ultra-fan Preeti Chhibber summed
everything up, calling it the
"...most comic booky movie Marvel has put
out. Second and third acts are outstanding.
The two post credit sequences are going to
stick in my brain for a L O N G time. I cannot
wait to see this movie at least three more
times. [...] My jaw dropped. And then dropped
again. It's a paradigm shift."
Yes, it appears that director Jon Watts, star
Tom Holland, and the rest of the crew have
absolutely knocked it out of the park on this
one, and we can't say that we're surprised.
After the massive success of both Captain
Marvel and Avengers: Endgame, it seems as
though Marvel is poised to have its third
mega-blockbuster of the year — and we'll
be the first in line to hand over our money.
See you there on July 2!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon. Subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one.